okay we have a voicemail number that is
two one nine to david p which you can
call any time of day at your leisure at
your pleasure whatever it is that
motivates you to call and for some
people it is the wish for the demise of
the david pakman show i mentioned
earlier when i told you about our
project to get 500 new financial
supporters of the show through
membership patreon or youtube
sponsorship that there are people
emailing me straight up wishing that we
fail here is an example of this type of
person who took the time to call in and
leave me this beautiful message of hope
and inspiration this show sucks the
blacks intelligent commentary right i
would say it's probably the worst show I
ever saw I don't know who funds your
show but it will be short-lived just
isn't interesting going on and on about
how pathetic Trump is your show is
pathetic you are pathetic why don't you
go ahead and turn your show into how to
deal with your homosexual desires to be
less homosexual and more of a productive
citizen what go ahead and focus your
show on that thank you
oh man so anyway you know not worth
three budding these individuals but they
are out there they exist they want to
see the show fail and I am confident
based on the initial response we've seen
from our audience to our proposal to add
five hundred supporters that we're gonna
succeed and this is going to be one sad
person and by the way the show's been
around for ten years so when he says
that it's going to be short-lived what
on earth is this guy talking about right
we've got a great bonus show coming up
for you today parkland students return
to school skeptical of clear backpacks
I've actually read quite a bit about the
clear backpack and clear purse a
policies that some concert venues have
been putting into place yellow cab
drivers and riders are concerned about a
new fee that is being put on yellow cabs
in some parts of the United States
including New York City we will also
talk about Scott Pruitt's bizarre condo
circum
dances and just the continued guess I'd
call them ethical questions about Scott
Pruitt's financial decisions as head of
the EPA all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership coupon code
is available vote soon 18 saves you 40%
and will speak to you that